Istilah quantum teleportation mungkin terdengar seperti fiksi ilmiah, tapi seperti yang akan kita bahas di episode hari ini
dari Qiskit in the Classroom, ini adalah teknik yang sangat nyata dan sangat berguna untuk komunikasi dan
jaringan kuantum. Selamat datang di Qiskit in the Classroom. Dalam seri ini, kita akan menggunakan Qiskit untuk menjelajahi beberapa konsep fundamental
yang umum dibahas dalam kursus terkait Quantum Computing. Setiap video disertai modul interaktif
yang ditautkan di deskripsi di bawah, jadi pastikan kamu lihat itu. Teleportasi adalah semacam klise fiksi ilmiah dan fantasi
pada titik ini. Seseorang atau objek menghilang dari satu lokasi dan langsung muncul di tempat lain.
Semenarik ini kedengarannya, sayangnya, jenis teleportasi ini setidaknya mustahil. Ini akan melanggar batas kecepatan kosmis.
Tidak ada yang bisa bergerak lebih cepat dari cahaya. Tapi quantum teleportation adalah
hal yang mungkin. Dalam quantum teleportation, informasi bukan materi bisa dikirimkan antara dua
lokasi yang jauh. Yang kamu butuhkan hanyalah sepasang partikel yang entangled, satu di setiap lokasi, dan cara untuk mengkomunikasikan informasi klasik
antara dua lokasi tersebut. Protokol ini dikembangkan pada tahun 1993 oleh sebuah tim
ilmuwan kuantum, termasuk Charles Bennett dari IBM. Mereka menyebutnya quantum teleportation karena mirip dengan
versi fiksi ilmiah, informasi kuantum menghilang dari satu lokasi dan muncul di lokasi lain yang jauh
tanpa pernah melewati ruang di antaranya. Mungkin terdengar seperti sihir, tapi seperti yang akan kita lihat, tidak ada
yang misterius atau ajaib tentang ini. Ini dimungkinkan oleh fenomena entanglement kuantum bersama dengan
komunikasi klasik. Hari ini kita akan membahas protokol quantum teleportation dan cara kerjanya. Lalu kita akan menerapkannya
di komputer kuantum nyata untuk menteleportasi state qubit dari satu sisi prosesor kuantum IBM ke
sisi lain. Jadi begini cara quantum teleportation bekerja. Misalkan kita punya dua orang Alice dan Bob yang terpisah
oleh jarak yang jauh. Katakanlah Alice punya sebuah qubit. Kita sebut qubit Q untuk kemudahan. Dan qubit itu berada dalam
state kuantum yang tidak diketahui sq di mana alpha 0 dan alpha 1 adalah bilangan
kompleks. Alice ingin mengirimkan statenya ke Bob, tapi dia tidak punya cara untuk benar-benar mengirimkan qubit itu sendiri. Bisa jadi
dia terlalu jauh, atau mungkin Alice bahkan tidak tahu persis di mana Bob berada, jadi dia tidak tahu ke mana harus mengirimnya. Beruntungnya,
kedua teman ini sudah berbagi sepasang qubit yang entangled yaitu A dan B, di mana Alice punya qubit A dan Bob punya qubit B. Dan
qubit-qubit ini entangled. Yang dimaksud entangled adalah meskipun dua qubit itu terpisah oleh jarak yang jauh,
state-state mereka berkorelasi dengan cara yang tidak bisa dijelaskan oleh fisika klasik. Pasangan yang entangled ini
disebut EBIT, yang bisa kita gunakan sebagai sumber daya dalam komputasi dan komunikasi kuantum.
Dalam kasus ini, Alice bisa menggunakan EBIT sebagai sumber daya untuk mengirimkan informasi kuantumnya ke Bob. Untuk melihat caranya, mari
mulai dengan menuliskan joint state dari ketiga qubit ini di mana aku telah mengurutkan qubit-qubit tersebut agak sembarang
untuk saat ini, tapi urutan ini akan nyaman saat kita menjalankan eksperimen di Qiskit. Di Qiskit, cara standar untuk
mengurutkan qubit adalah dari kanan ke kiri. Jadi, state qubit nol akan muncul di sebelah kanan.
Mari kita perluas state sedikit dan tulis ulang seperti ini. Kemudian langkah pertama dalam protokol teleportasi kita adalah
Alice meng-entangle qubit data-nya dengan separuh EBIT miliknya menggunakan CNOT gate. CNOT atau controlled NOT
gate akan mengubah state satu qubit, qubit target, bergantung pada state qubit lain, qubit kontrol.
Jika qubit kontrol berada dalam state nol, maka tidak ada yang terjadi pada target. Dan jika qubit kontrol berada dalam
state satu, maka qubit target dibalik. Jadi dalam kasus ini, qubit data Q milik Alice akan menjadi qubit kontrol dan
qubit EBIT A miliknya akan menjadi qubit target. Jadi dua suku pertama tidak berubah sama sekali oleh CNOT, tapi dua
suku terakhir berubah karena qubit kontrol Q berada dalam state satu. Kemudian Alice
akan menerapkan Hadamard gate pada qubit data Q-nya yang mengubah state 0 menjadi state 1/2 (0 + 1) dan state 1 menjadi
1/2 (0 - 1). Aku akan melewatkan beberapa aljabar sederhana di sini yang bisa kamu coba isi sendiri kalau mau.
Tapi setelah menyusun ulang beberapa suku kamu akan mendapatkan state yang terlihat seperti ini. Jadi sekarang state tiga qubit
yang entangled antara Alice dan Bob terlihat berantakan. Tapi perhatikan apa yang terjadi kalau Alice mengukur kedua qubitnya. State tiga
qubit akan runtuh sebagian menjadi salah satu dari empat
suku ini. Dan dalam setiap kasus, Bob akan mendapatkan state superposisi dengan amplitudo yang terkait dengan
state awal yang tidak diketahui milik Alice. Ingat amplitudonya adalah alpha 0 dan alpha 1. Jadi
misalnya, jika Alice mengukur kedua qubit menjadi nol, maka state Bob akan runtuh ke suku ini, yaitu state awal
yang tidak diketahui yang ingin diteleportasi Alice. Tapi jika Alice mengukur nol pada qubit A dan satu pada qubit Q, maka state
Bob akan seperti ini. State ini bisa diubah menjadi state asli qubit Q jika Bob
menerapkan Z gate, yang akan membalik tanda di sini. Tapi Bob tidak akan tahu harus melakukan ini
sampai dia tahu apa yang diukur Alice. Jadi langkah berikutnya dalam protokol adalah Alice menghubungi Bob dan memberitahunya apa
hasil dua pengukurannya. Setelah dia tahu itu, dia akan tahu operasi apa yang harus dilakukan pada qubitnya untuk membuatnya cocok dengan
state asli Alice. Ini adalah tabel empat kemungkinan pengukuran dan empat kemungkinan operasi yang harus
dilakukan Bob pada qubitnya berdasarkan pengukuran tersebut. Bob mungkin perlu melakukan Z gate, X gate, atau keduanya untuk
mengubah qubitnya agar cocok dengan qubit asli Alice. Langkah terakhir ini, di mana Alice menghubungi Bob, ngomong-ngomong, adalah mengapa
quantum teleportation tidak melanggar kausalitas. Meskipun state Bob langsung runtuh saat Alice mengukur
qubitnya, Bob tidak bisa mendapatkan informasi apa pun dari state itu sampai Alice memberitahu Bob apa yang dia ukur. Dan
telepon itu dibatasi oleh kecepatan cahaya. Kita baru saja melalui banyak matematika yang detail, jadi fakta luar biasa
bahwa kita baru saja menteleportasi informasi kuantum mungkin tidak terasa. Tapi ini benar-benar cukup menakjubkan. Dengan menggunakan
entanglement sebagai sumber daya, Alice bisa melakukan pengukuran untuk menghancurkan informasi kuantum yang disimpan padanya dan membuatnya
muncul di lokasi lain yang jauh bersama Bob. Jarak ini bisa ratusan, bahkan ribuan kilometer. Bahkan lebih
menakjubkan lagi, protokol ini bahkan tidak mengharuskan Alice mengetahui persis di mana Bob berada. Selama mereka berbagi EBIT
dan bisa berkomunikasi secara klasik satu sama lain, quantum teleportation akan bekerja. Sekarang, mari kita lihat bagaimana ini bekerja
WEBVTT
dengan Qiskit dan benar-benar menteleportasi state kuantum di komputer kuantum.
Kita akan mulai dengan tiga qubit, satu masing-masing untuk qubit data Q dan qubit A dan B yang akan membentuk EBIT. Kita
mulai dengan membuat EBIT. Kita menerapkan Hadamard pada qubit A diikuti oleh CNOT
antara A dan B untuk membuat state yang entangled yang kita inginkan.
Kemudian kita menyiapkan qubit Q milik Alice dalam state kuantum acak dengan menerapkan unitary acak yang ditunjukkan oleh kotak berlabel
U. Kemudian datanglah teleportasi. Pertama CNOT antara qubit Q dan A. Kemudian Hadamard pada
qubit Q. Kemudian pengukuran meruntuhkan state sebagian sehingga hanya qubit B milik Bob yang berada dalam superposisi.
Inilah titik di mana Alice akan menghubungi Bob dan memberitahunya apa yang dia ukur. Kemudian Bob akan menerapkan beberapa
gate bergantung pada pengukuran tersebut. Kotak-kotak dengan garis merah ini menandakan conditional gate. Yang pertama berarti
Bob menerapkan X gate pada qubitnya jika qubit A diukur menjadi satu. Dan
yang kedua berarti dia akan menerapkan Z gate juga jika qubit Q diukur menjadi satu.
Jadi sekarang Bob seharusnya memiliki qubit dalam state yang sama dengan state qubit Alice pada titik ini setelah unitary gate.
Jika semuanya berjalan sesuai rencana, maka kita telah menteleportasi state kuantum. Tapi bagaimana cara kita memeriksanya? Kita bisa menjalankan
circuit yang sama tapi dengan satu perubahan kecil.
Di sini kita telah menambahkan unitary lain di bagian akhir circuit yang diterapkan pada qubit Bob. Unitary ini adalah kebalikan dari
yang kita terapkan di awal pada qubit Alice. Alasannya adalah jika gate pertama ini membuat
state kuantum yang sekarang diteleportasi ke qubit Bob, maka yang ini seharusnya membatalkannya, membawa qubit Bob kembali ke state
nol. Tapi tentu saja, ini membatalkan semua kerja keras kita menteleportasi state tadi. Jadi kita tidak ingin
melakukan ini kalau kita benar-benar ingin melakukan sesuatu dengan state yang diteleportasi dan kalau itu benar-benar dalam state kuantum yang tidak diketahui
kita tidak akan bisa menerapkan unitary untuk membatalkannya. Bagaimanapun, ini murni untuk tujuan diagnostik untuk memastikan
bahwa teleportasi berhasil. Kalau kita mengukur qubit Bob berada dalam state nol, maka kita bisa cukup yakin
bahwa teleportasi berhasil. Setelah kita yakin bahwa protokol kita berjalan sesuai harapan, kita bisa menghapus
unitary terakhir ini dan benar-benar melakukan sesuatu dengan state yang diteleportasi. Tapi untuk sekarang, mari kita pastikan saja ini berjalan. Mari
jalankan circuit di komputer kuantum. Kita bisa menggunakan Qiskit primitive sampler untuk menjalankan circuit ini
berkali-kali dan mengumpulkan statistik tentang hasil pengukuran. Kalau kita berhasil menteleportasi state Alice ke Bob setiap
saat, maka Bob akan mengukur qubitnya menjadi nol setiap saat, tapi dengan noise lingkungan dan ketidaksempurnaan dalam
gate, kita bisa mengharapkan beberapa run di mana qubit Bob berakhir menjadi satu. Tapi selama sebagian besar
waktu qubit Bob diukur menjadi nol, kita bisa menyebutnya berhasil. Di sini kita punya histogram dari hasil pengukuran
dari ketiga qubit. Pengukuran Bob ditampilkan sebagai slot pertama dari setiap string tiga bit. Seperti yang diharapkan, empat
hasil yang sesuai dengan bit-nya menjadi nol jauh lebih mungkin daripada keempat lainnya. Jadi, kita berhasil
menteleportasi state kuantum. Tapi perhatikan seberapa jauh kita menteleportasi. Ini adalah peta semua
qubit pada prosesor kuantum yang kita gunakan. Dan dalam eksperimen ini, kita hanya menggunakan ketiga qubit ini.
Qubit Alice ada di sini dan qubit Bob ada di sini. Jadi, mereka hampir berdampingan. Kita bisa
mencapai hal yang sama hanya dengan menerapkan beberapa swap gate, yang seperti namanya, hanya menukar state kuantum
dari dua qubit yang bertetangga. Quantum teleportation berguna untuk mengangkut informasi kuantum dalam jarak jauh, dan
state kuantum telah berhasil diteleportasi ratusan kilometer sebelumnya. Untuk eksperimen kita di sini, kita dibatasi oleh
ukuran chip, tapi kita bisa membuat teleportasi sedikit lebih mengesankan dengan menteleportasi state antara dua
qubit yang berjauhan di komputer kuantum kita. Jadi, mari kita coba itu. Ini adalah diagram circuit baru kita. Terlihat sedikit lebih
rumit, tapi tidak ada yang berubah secara fundamental kecuali sekarang Alice dan Bob membuat EBIT bersama mereka,
kemudian berpisah. Serangkaian garis dan X ini mewakili swap gate yang memindahkan
state Alice dan Bob dari satu qubit ke qubit lainnya. Alice berpindah ke qubit 1 dan
Bob berpindah ke qubit 12. Kemudian Alice membuat state acaknya pada qubit 0 dengan
unitary ini. Ingat bahwa dia membuat state setelah dia dan Bob sudah
berpisah. Jadi Bob sudah jauh darinya.
Kemudian protokol teleportasi berlanjut seperti sebelumnya dan Bob berakhir dengan state asli Alice setelah
operasi kondisionalnya. Kita menerapkan inverse unitary gate dan kemudian memeriksa bahwa qubit Bob
berada dalam state nol. Dan sekali lagi kita melihat bahwa sebagian besar waktu qubit Bob ditemukan berada dalam state
nol. Jadi teleportasi berhasil.
Tingkat keberhasilan tidak setinggi saat Alice dan Bob berdampingan. Semua swap gate itu
bisa mahal dan menyebabkan EBIT sedikit terdegradasi. Quantum teleportation mungkin terlihat seperti sihir, tapi seperti yang telah
kita lihat, yang dibutuhkan hanyalah entanglement, saluran komunikasi klasik, dan sedikit kecerdasan. Proposal tahun 1993
yang telah kita bahas dalam video ini menjadi fondasi untuk protokol lain seperti quantum gate
teleportation dan merupakan bahan penting untuk komputasi dan komunikasi kuantum.
Di bidang eksperimental, para ilmuwan terus mendorong batas quantum teleportation, bahkan berhasil menteleportasi
state kuantum sebuah foton antara laboratorium di Bumi dan sebuah satelit 1.400 km
di atasnya. Dan menteleportasi state kuantum melalui kabel internet klasik yang berisik. Kalau kamu ingin menteleportasi
state kuantum kamu sendiri, kunjungi modul quantum teleportation yang ditautkan di deskripsi di bawah. Terima kasih sudah menonton
dan sampai jumpa lain kali.